bad events make people grow I mean up to
a point of course about events it can be
you know something that that kills you
it doesn't make you grow but so so
there's something called post-traumatic
growth and psychologists don't talk
about it all they talk about the
disorder and and the idea that nobody's
going to make any money selling you you
know post-traumatic growth they give you
because they don't have to treat you
make sure it's treating you okay well
psychologists make money giving you
advice on your post traumatic Disorder
so they like to put disorders and then
of course the anti-fragile a lot of
people up regulate
on the stressor
that's supposed traumatic growth in
other words if you need stressors you
must get your stressors
so you know they're going to be wind and
there's an expression in in the states
when life gives you a lemon you make
lemonade the idea is that you know
there's going to be a lot of wind so
either you're going to the basement and
start crying and ask for government
money all right or there's going to be a
lot of win to say oh I'm going to make
some money out of it
big wood bills so the the that's the the
main one and and if you look at the
history of civilization and countries
you see a parameter a little bit of
stressor has caused a lot of people to
do very well
I think the most successful country in
history Singapore they have no resources
so when you don't have resources you
tend to upregulate the Phoenicians had
no resources that forced them to you
know become merchants and one thing
leads to another so it gets you out of
the the
lithurgical states and you look at Saudi
Arabia they have all the resources and
look what they've done with them
compared to Singapore
in an only chapter of the book you'll
have a very long table yeah with three
columns Yes Fragile robust and
anti-fragile and you can pick any of the
rows in that in that table and elaborate
on it for example
tourists and flannel
one of your favorite words
there is something quite deep in in that
in this life
okay I was an option Trader option you
like optionality you see you like
uncertainty you benefit from uncertainty
you you like some disorder when you're a
tourist
you're on the track if the bus is late
you're in trouble
if you're an adventurer you you benefit
you have you're opportunistically taken
advantage of uncertainty so therefore
you're in that category of anti-fragile
if you're robust you don't care
so the idea of entrepreneurs are in a
category of anti-fragile
and the people who have you know very
rationalistic think put on track you're
following a you know
a certain code
you are fragile because if something
breaks you're in trouble you can't
nothing good you know Can Can Happen
things can go wrong but they can get
better so the fragile has more downside
than upside
uncertainty harm them take a plane ride
if you inject uncertainty into a plane
ride
I just came from Europe it was eight
hours
ended up to be 16.
so that was eight hours late
did anyone have you ever land in JFK
coming from Europe eight hours early
no that's so category you inject
uncertainty the the the travel time
extends the opposite would be a system
in which you inject uncertainty you have
benefits and that's the anti-fragile
entrepreneurship
if you're an adventurer
you like uncertainty
and people you know couldn't get it and
I have a way to explain it someone tells
me what's the difference was resilient
it says there's a big difference
if I buy insurance on my house and 10
times the amount needed
and you know I want an accident to
happen
you see it's not as I wanna every day a
morning I'd wake up I say there's no cow
no earthquake nothing in fact 10 times I
get paid 10 times the damages
so that's like inverse insurance
so insurance companies of course are
short volatility are harmed by disorders
they are fragile
and someone who has ten times insurance
would you know benefit from uncertainty
I think that education is not very good
because in higher doses because it's
sort of uh it's selects for those who
don't know how to handle uncertainty
right and this is why people a great
scientists like Darwin Einstein
grotonic all the big big the big big
scientists are people who were not
into the traditional you know education
system simply because it kills
creativity and all that stuff so when I
was a about 14 I decided to become a
writer so and I realized that if you
stick to school it Narrows what you're
going to know all right and to be a
writer you have to read a lot of books
so I started reading wholesale and and
it saved me the the bad part of
Education where you have you know to
read a certain number of books and uh so
the narrow education the broader one I
think that's what saved me from from uh
from from this uh you know race against
certain race so
um and then so I had an auntie and then
I developed you know very quickly in
anti-uh education I think the only way
you can learn things if you're
autodidact
and it allows you not just to have the
breadth of things you know but to focus
on things that that are really important
to you not to some second rate person
who teaches High School right and I
hated my high school teachers uh
you can understand it was quite
rebellious so that's uh
okay so so it was a uh so I I think that
that that helped me a lot reading a lot
of books The Great American uh author
Mark Twain once said I never let School
get in the way of my education
um that writers usually don't like
formal education so but obviously in a
in an engineered World in a world that's
so technically complicated you've got to
have you know you to deal with it you
have to you have to have some
educational it's good to have a minimal
uh education but not to focus on school
because anything people around tissue at
school is useless already or else have
been used so one thing you learn as a
Trader anything you're going to read the
newspaper
uh say the first 15 pages of the
newspaper is of absolutely no relevance
to anything it's already priced in so so
that's the way uh you know it's the same
way to view education so if you compare
apprenticeship which is more tinkering
trial and error more doing things
apprenticeship is is something very
prevalent in Switzerland and Germany and
I don't know about Nordic countries
that's vastly more important than
education
well I mean most people don't understand
what stoic is and they think that
historic uh wants to sort of be robust
North positive nor negative emotions get
rid of uh
you know Detachment from the world yeah
exactly so so in other words become a
vegetable and and that's that's the
impression that
that for about two thousand years
mostly because nobody really read them
so so people kept commenting on on
comments but when I read the best
expository of the story says the best
tourist spot is actually Marcus Aurelius
and Seneca and and probably also to some
extent Cicero I realize these are not
that type of people
very different and uh and and now
recently I saw some papers confirming my
idea that that what Seneca was is about
being long options
he wanted to keep the upside and not be
hurt by the downside that's it it's just
how to set up his message Seneca was the
wealthiest man in the world
he had 500 desks okay on which he wrote
his uh his letters uh talking how about
about how good it was to before okay and
and people found inconsistency but they
didn't realize that Seneca said he was
not against wealth
you see and he proved you know that that
effectively one one that that that uh
philosopher can have wealth and can be a
philosopher what he was about is
dependence on wealth he wanted the
upside of wealth without his downside
and what he would do is he had been a
shipwreck uh before he would uh uh fake
like he's a shipwreck and travel like a
shipwreck once in a while
and then he would go back to his uh you
know Villas and and uh and feel rich
he would write down write off every
night before going to bed his entire
wealth
as a mental exercise
and wake up rich yeah so he was he was
it was he kept the upside in fact what
they had is my
uh whereabouts is as follows I mean the
people who really had like Buddhist was
an attitude wanted to have the last word
with faith and my definition is I said
the the story says someone who
transforms fear into prudence
into information
mistakes into initiation and desire into
undertaking
so it's very different from the Buddhist
idea of someone who is you know
completely separated from worldly
sentiments and possessions and uh and
thrills it was very different it's
someone who wanted the upside of that
downside
and Seneca proved it and the way you get
there is Seneca is suggesting is through
mental uh exertion through we're not
through necessarily some of its action
obviously but some of it is the way you
look at your life and what you prepare
yourself for and what how you affect
your expectations exactly he understood
the hedonic treadmill you know that Dan
economy rediscovered about 2400 2000
years later he understood it very well
and he understood that wealth he said
well you're in debt when you have wealth
whether you are in debt from you know
the steps from others or from Fortune
you see and he wanted to write off that
uh that that that that fortune and he
wanted to remove his dependence on faith
on Randomness he wanted to have the last
word was randomness
and he did not a bad goal
so here I've introduced the book
and I end the book with the following
the only way you know you're alive
you're not a machine is if you like
variability so this is it if you're
anti-fragile it means you're alive now
let me leave you with some quotes and
ideas related to these rules do hard
things let's hear Navarro we can't take
on this you know look at the kids who
are born rich no meanings to their lives
you're a terrible Place yeah your real
your real resume is just a cataloging of
all your suffering right if I were to
ask you to describe your real life to
yourself when you look back in your
deathbed you're going to go back and say
what are the interesting things I've
done and it's all going to be around the
sacrifices that you've made and the hard
things that you did anything you're
given doesn't matter you know you you
have your four limbs you have your brain
you have your head you have your skin
that's that's all for granted so you
have to do hard things anyway to create
your own meaning in life quote from
Seneca no man is more unhappy than he
who never faces adversity for he is not
permitted to prove himself
go through life as a flanner Nasim taleb
growth if you know in the morning what
your day looks like with any Precision
you're a little bit dead the more
Precision the more debt you are
you have a calibrated life with most of
what you fear has a titling Prospect of
Adventure develop an anti-education
quote from nacinta Lab only the auto
detects are free and now a quote from
Jim Rohn formal education will make you
a living
self-education will make you a fortune
adopt an anti-fragile life philosophy on
his book Letters From A stoic Seneca
growth set aside a certain number of
days during which you shall be content
with a scantist and cheapest fare with
coarse and rough dress saying to
yourself the while is this the condition
that I feared Tim Ferriss is also known
for following this practice let's hear
it from him for inoculating yourself
against that fear of loss failure
especially for things outside of your
control
I always talk about it but I'll talk
about it again is letters from A stoic
by Seneca like training yourself I've
given hundreds of copies of this book
away the ability to inoculate yourself
against fear by training so for instance
like spending four or five days not even
that much two days a month where you eat
the cheapest food where the cheapest
clothing
don't use Transportation then you ask
yourself you know all along is this the
condition I so feared totally and then
your fear failure like this isn't so bad
I can do fine thank you for watching and
now a quick blog for my new adventure we
are living in an endless cycle of
ephemeral content consumption we are
mostly consuming new information that is
being created in the last few days or
hours but time is the ultimate stressor
of information and the Lindy effect
states that the longer an idea has been
relevant the longer it will still be
relevant therefore Timeless ideas are
the most robust and useful this is why
I'm creating the little Almanac a
newsletter which is actually more of an
anti-newsletter as it only has Timeless
ideas which is the opposite of news
every Friday I send out a nugget from an
influential doer in their own words the
doers are the major thinkers usually
when you dig a Little Deeper you find
that the people that really did it were
also the people that really work through
the hard intellectual problems as well
doers who took the time to share
timeless principles through books or
interviews on how to get better how to
get richer and how to improve our
judgment and depending on the week I
focus on a specific area also I draw
visual to make the Nugget more clear and
memorable and afterwards I deliver a
little reflection if you would like to
get all this every Friday just click the
link on the right side of the screen to
sign up for free you can also find it in
the video description below